>>> THIS MORNING A NEW 77-PAGE
FAILURES IN LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
RESPONSE TO THE UVALDE SCHOOL
MASSACRE.
IT DESCRIBES A, QUOTE,
LACKADAISICAL APPROACH BY NEARLY
400 OFFICERS FROM MANY DIFFERENT
AGENCIES ON THE SCENE THAT DAY.
THE REPORT BLAMES A LACK OF
EFFECTIVE INCIDENT COMMAND AND A
FAILURE TO FOLLOW ACTIVE SHOOTER
TRAINING.
THE UVALDE MAYOR IS VOWING TO
INVESTIGATE EVERY OFFICER'S
ACTIONS.
HE'S ALSO LASHED OUT ABOUT HOW
THIS ENTIRE INVESTIGATION HAS
BEEN HANDLED.
>> WE'RE TIRED OF THE [ BLEEP ],
WE'RE TIRED OF THE [ BLEEP ]
STORIES AND WE'RE TIRED OF YOU
SAYING NO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE COOPERATING.
THAT WAS THEIR STATEMENT.
THE CITY OF UVALDE AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT POLICE OFFICE
HAS NOT COOPERATED SINCE DAY
ONE.
AND THAT IS A LIE.
WE HAVE GIVEN 100% ANYTHING THEY
HAVE ASKED FOR.
>> YOU CAN FEEL HIS ANGER
THROUGH THE SCREEN.
WITH ME NOW IS CHIEF JIMMY
PERDUE.
HE LEADS THE NORTH RICHMOND
HILLS POLICE DEPARTMENT AND ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE TEXAS POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU'VE BEEN CLEAR IN SAYING OUR
PROFESSION FAILED THE FAMILIES
IN UVALDE AND THOSE CHILDREN AND
TEACHERS.
WHAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
YOU LEARNED READING THIS REPORT?
>> WELL, IT PRETTY MUCH
CONFIRMED ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
HAD FEARED ABOUT WHAT HAD
ACTUALLY TOOK PLACE, IS THAT THE
OFFICERS, DESPITE INFORMATION
THAT WAS VERY CLEAR TO THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AS WELL AS OTHERS,
THE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THEY
GOT FROM 911 CALLS AND JUST FROM
HEARING THINGS FAILED TO ACT.
THEY FAILED TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE THREAT OF DANGER, TO SECURE
THE SCENE, TO TAKE CARE OF THE
ATTACKER AND TO SAVE AS MANY
KIDS AS POSSIBLE.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S -- I THINK THE
REPORT CORRECTLY STATED IT WAS A
SYSTEMATIC FAILURE.
THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WENT WRONG, A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO
DO, A LOT OF THINGS TO JUSTIFY
TO THE COMMUNITY OF UVALDE.
BUT WE AS A PROFESSION DID NOT
DO WELL THAT DAY.
>> WE JUST HEARD IN JIM'S
INTERVIEW WITH RONALD GARZA, THE
COUNTY COMMISSIONER IN UVALDE,
SAYING OTHER AGENCIES, OTHER
COMMANDERS COULD HAVE TAKEN
ACTION SOONER.
IS THERE ANY LESSON IN THAT FOR
WHO SHOULD HAVE JUMPED IN?
BECAUSE WE KNOW PETE ARREDONDO,
WHO'S GOTTEN THE LION'S SHARE OF
ATTENTION FOR BEING IN CHARGE
THAT DAY, TESTIFIED TO THIS
HOUSE COMMITTEE HE DIDN'T THINK
HE WAS IN CHARGE.
>> YEAH, THAT IS -- I'VE
EXPLAINED DURING MY TESTIMONY
DOWN AT THE TEXAS LEGISLATURE,
TRYING TO EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENS
IN AN ACTIVE SCENE WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT MANY PEOPLE TOGETHER IN A
SINGLE ENVIRONMENT FROM
DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
AND OUR NATURAL TENDENCY IS TO
DEFAULT TO THE LOCAL AGENCY OF
WHO IS IN CHARGE.
YOU SAW THAT ON BODY CAMERA.
YOU SAW PEOPLE DEFERRING TO THE
CHIEF BECAUSE THEY KNEW HE WAS
THERE IN THE ROOM, AND HE WAS
VERBALIZING SOME OF HIS
INSTRUCTIONS.
THAT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT HE WAS
IN CHARGE.
SO, IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT THING
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL OFFICER TO GO
PAST THE CHAIN OF COMMAND AND
TAKE INDEPENDENT ACTION.
CLEARLY, WITH HINDSIGHT, WE KNOW
THAT THAT'S WHAT SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
SOMEBODY SHOULD HAVE STEPPED UP.
I BELIEVE IF SOMEBODY HAD
STEPPED UP AND SAID, I'M GOING
IN, I BELIEVE THAT OTHERS WOULD
HAVE FOLLOWED.
>> AND I WONDER IF YOU THINK
LIVES COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED?
BECAUSE THE REPORT DOES SAY THEY
DON'T KNOW, YOU KNOW, THEY DON'T
KNOW IF EARLIER ACTION WAS TAKEN
IN LIVES COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED.
AT THE SAME TIME THE REPORT SAYS
IT'S PLAUSIBLE THAT SOME VICTIMS
COULD HAVE SURVIVED IF THEY HAD
NOT HAD TO WAIT.
WE KNOW SOME OF THESE VICTIMS
BLED OUT ON THE WAY TO THE
HOSPITAL.
SO, I WONDER -- I WONDER WHAT
YOU THINK THE LESSON IS THERE.
I MEAN, ONE OF THE RELATIVES
WE'RE HAVING ON NEXT HOUR SAID,
AT LEAST THEY COULD HAVE HELD
THEIR HAND WHILE THEY WERE
DYING.
AT LEAST THEY WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
TO HAVE BEEN ALONE.
>> AND THAT IS THE DIFFICULT
PART FOR A FAMILY MEMBER,
KNOWING THEY WERE IN THE ROOM
ALONE.
AS THE REPORT CORRECTLY STATED
AGAIN, THE SHOT LIKELY THAT MOST
OF THE STUDENTS DIED FROM THE
INITIAL VOLLEY OF GUNFIRE, GIVEN
THE AMOUNT OF GUNFIRE, BEFORE
THE OFFICERS EVER WENT INTO THE
ROOM.
BUT I THINK THAT WE'LL NEVER
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
WE'LL NEVER KNOW IF LIVES COULD
HAVE BEEN STATED, AS THE REPORT
STATED.
THE FACT THERE WERE SOME
STUDENTS TRANSPORTED STILL
ALIVE, BUT DIED ON THE WAY TO
THE HOSPITAL.
ANYONE WOULD INDICATE THAT IF
YOU COULD HAVE GOT TO THEM 77 OR
70 MINUTES EARLIER, LIKELY THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN SOME PEOPLE THAT
SURVIVED MORE BECAUSE OF
BLEEDING OUT THAT TOOK PLACE.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM THE 911 CALLS,
FROM THE STUDENT THAT CALLED
THAT SAID THERE WERE KIDS ALIVE
WHEN SHE CALLED, SO WE KNOW
THERE WERE ONES ALIVE AT LEAST
AT SOME POINT.
AND TAKING MORE INITIAL ACTION
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE AND
HOPEFULLY REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
SOMEBODY COULD HAVE DIED.
WE'LL NEVER KNOW FOR SURE,
OBVIOUSLY, BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING DIFFICULT TO PROVE.
CLEARLY, ALL INDICATIONS ARE
THAT THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ACTIONS EARLIER IN THAT PROCESS
TO GO INSIDE THAT ROOM.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LAWS IN
THE STATE OF TEXAS, BECAUSE THE
SUPREME COURT HAS JUST GIVEN
STATES MORE POWER IN CERTAIN
WAYS AND RESTRICTED STATES IN
CERTAIN WAYS FROM MAKING GUN
LAWS.
YOU'VE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT YOU
CAN'T STOP BAD GUYS FROM GETTING
GUNS, BUT YOU SAID YOU THINK
IT'S TIME FOR TEXAS TO MAKE AN
EFFORT TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
SOME PEOPLE TO GET GUNS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS GUN WAS
PURCHASED LEGALLY AFTER THE
SHOOTER, ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT, TRIED TO GET GUNS
THROUGH FAMILY, THROUGH WHAT ARE
KNOWN AS STRAW PURCHASES.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SEE IN TERMS
OF GUN LAWS CHANGE IN TEXAS?
BECAUSE THEY CHANGE QUICKLY IN
FLORIDA AFTER THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
>> THEY DID.
AND WE IN TEXAS HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF GUN OWNERSHIP, AND WE
ARE A PROUD SUPPORTER OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT THROUGH THE
TEXAS POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
BUT AS I'VE SATATED BEFORE, I
BELIEVE THERE ARE REASONABLE
MEASURES THAT CAN BE PUT IN
PLACE THAT MAY STOP SOMEONE FROM
GETTING ACCESS TO A WEAPON
SOONER THAN THEY SHOULD.
AND WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
THOSE AVENUES.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT IT'S GOING
TO STOP EVERYTHING, BECAUSE BAD
GUYS ARE STILL GOING TO GET
GUNS.
BUT I THINK IF WE CAN PREVENT
SOME -- ONE OR TWO OF THESE
EVENTS FROM OCCURRING, I THINK
IT'S WORTH THAT INCONVENIENCE
THAT MAY COME FROM HAVING --
RAISING THE AGE FROM 18 TO 21,
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE FOR STRAW
PURCHASES IN TEXAS, AND LOOKING
AT WAYS WE CAN GET MORE MENTAL
HEALTH INFORMATION TO THE
OFFICERS IN THE FIELD SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE BETTER DECISIONS
WHENEVER THEY'RE ENCOUNTERING
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
RIGHT NOW, THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO ALL THAT INFORMATION
THEY SHOULD WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE THOSE FIELD DECISIONS,
BECAUSE AGAIN, WE TALK SO MUCH
ABOUT THE SYSTEMS AND THE WAY
THAT THINGS ARE BEING DONE
ACROSS THE STATE OF TEXAS, BUT
THE REALITY IS MOST OF THE WORK
IS DONE BY THE STREET OFFICER AT
3:00 IN THE AFTERNOON OR 3:00 IN
THE MORNING, WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE A SOUND DECISION AND
THEY NEED INFORMATION TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS.
>> IT'S POWERFUL TO HEAR THAT
FROM YOU, SIR, AS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE TEXAS POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND A SUPPORTER OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT CAN
CHANGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU, POPPY.
JOINING ME TO DISCUSS IS UVALDE
COUNTY COMMISSIONER GARZA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON
YOUR SHOW.
>> IT'S A LONG LIST OF UPSETTING
REVELATIONS, FRANKLY, FROM THESE
VIDEOS AND THE REPORT.
AS I WAS SAYING TO SHIMON, THE
BIGGEST SEEMS TO BE THAT
MULTIPLE FOLKS FAILED HERE AND
SEEMED TO GO AGAINST THEIR
TRAINING IN TERMS OF CONFRONTING
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
FIRST QUESTION IS, IN YOUR VIEW,
SHOULD SEVERAL OF THE RESPONDING
OFFICERS, NOT JUST ARREDONDO,
FACE REPERCUSSIONS?
>> WELL, JIM, THE BIG TAKEAWAY
YESTERDAY, FROM YESTERDAY'S
PRESS CONFERENCE, AS
REPRESENTATIVE BURROWS AND
REPRESENTATIVE MOODY AND GUZMAN
CONVEYED TO THE PRESS YESTERDAY
AND THE AUDIENCE WAS THAT THERE
WERE VARIOUS SHORTCOMINGS AND
FAILURES ON THE PART OF THE
MULTIPLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT WERE THERE ON THAT
TRAGIC DAY.
THE BIG TAKEAWAY, I THINK, IN MY
OPINION, FROM THE COMMITTEE WAS
THAT, YES, THE SCHOOL COMMANDER
WAS IN CHARGE, BUT OTHER --
OTHER AGENCIES OR OTHER
INDIVIDUALS COULD HAVE TAKEN
OVER THE SCENE.
>> ONE OTHER -- AGAIN, IT'S A
LONG LIST OF REVELATIONS HERE.
EARLY ON IN THIS, THERE WERE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
INFORMATION SHARING.
FOR INSTANCE, DID THE OFFICERS
INSIDE THAT HALLWAY KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A CHILD CALLING 911
WHO WAS ALIVE INSIDE THE ROOM?
WE NOW KNOW THEY DID KNOW.
IT'S ON THE TAPE.
IT'S ON THE BODY CAM FOOTAGE.
PRESIDENT 911 DISPATCHER WITH A
DIRECT LINE TO THE OFFICERS
SAYING, THERE'S A CHILD ON THE
LINE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> YES.
>> HOW COULD THEY NOT KNOW
THERE'S A CHILD WOUNDED IN THERE
AND THEN USE THAT AS THE SPARK
FOR ACTIONS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE VIDEO
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
IT WAS VERY REVEALING.
AND THAT WAS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE YESTERDAY BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT THERE WERE
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWNS AT THE
SCENE OF THAT DAY.
SO, YES, BREAKDOWNS,
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWNS, AND,
YOU KNOW, AS THE RESULT, YOU
KNOW, YOU HAD THAT DELAY BEFORE
ACTION WAS TAKEN.